Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P Here is a voicemail
asking a really interesting question
about audio books versus physical books.
Speaker 6: Hey, David, this is only from
Dallas. I love all of your book recommendations.
Thank you. I've read quite a few of them, but
I've never heard your position on audiobooks.
What do you audiobooks do you think that it's
a cheap way of reading a book, or do you think
that it's useful for people who are often,
you know, busy with a lot of things going
on and just want to hear the book in audio form?
Speaker 1: Okay, so here's the deal. The answer
to our audio books, as good as physical books,
you have to first say as good. In what way? Okay.
I read fiction at night before going to bed.
The physical process of holding the book and
actually reading it is the point. So in that case,
my fiction reading at night before going to bed,
an audio book is not a good substitute. If the
idea is to get information from a nonfiction book,
then the audio book, while driving in the car or
at the gym or whatever, is a better substitute.
So you have to ask yourself, what is it that
I'm trying to do with the book or with the
information? There is one thing about audiobooks
that's not quite as useful, I would say,
which is that the normal way we read, you read a
bunch of lines and then you go back half a line
and then you double check a word. That's a normal
process where you might say to yourself, Oh, no,
I don't do that. I just read straightforward.
No, I understand. We do it naturally,
particularly with more difficult texts. You
kind of read back and go up a line or two. You
can't really have that same process with the
audiobooks. Now I get it. You can hit back 15
seconds and hear something again, but it is
different in the brain. So the studies that
have been done are that audiobooks are great
substitutes for physical books in many ways,
but it is not the same experience. And so
the the answer to the question is it as good?
You have to then follow up and say as good
in what particular way? We have a great bonus
show for you today. We're going to talk about
the threats and the suspicious powder set to
Manhattan District Attorney Alvin Brack. We are
also going to talk about the FTC getting involved
in making it easier to quit gym memberships, gym
memberships. And who is Ro Khanna endorsing in
the California Senate race? Is it Adam Schiff?
Is it Barbara Lee or is it Katie Porter? Well,
it is. Barbara Lee. We will discuss with
you Roxana's endorsement and much more,
all of it on the bonus show. Get access by signing
up at join Pat MINKOFF. See you then, everybody.